welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is David blight
he is class of 1954 professor of
American history and the director of the
Gilder Lehrman Center for the Study of
slavery and abolition at the Macmillan
Center
he has written numerous books and
articles on race and American history
and has been featured in many
documentary films about American history
on PBS the BBC and other networks today
we'll talk with Professor blight about
his new book frederick douglass prophet
of freedom which was selected as one of
the new york times book reviews ten best
books of 2018
welcome professor blight Thank You
Marilyn good to be back with you yes it
is a pleasure to have you on again and
if I recall last time you're on we
talked about slave no more which was
born out of accounts written by two
freed slaves and the and they're rare
and they were entrusted to you to you
know write that book and history seems
to be repeating itself because here we
are with you again today and you were
given access to new materials on
Frederick Douglass so my question to you
is what was it like to be given and
especially after studying studying for
Frederick Douglass your whole life what
was it like for you to get your hands on
that material extraordinary and I had
put Douglass essentially out of my life
by about 10-12 years ago I wasn't gonna
write anymore about Douglas Douglas I
wrote my first book on Douglass but then
Douglass had been some part of every
other book I'd written a little bit
anyway and then I had the great good
luck of encountering a collector a
collector extraordinaire who lives in
Savannah Georgia his name is Walter
Evans
he
is an african-american retired surgeon
who grew up in segregated Savannah but
he went north for his higher education
did his medical school at Michigan and
practiced for 35 years or so in Detroit
but his real passion in life and he
started his collecting in the 1970's and
early 80's is collecting
african-american art rare books and
manuscripts and I went to Savannah to
give a talk to high school teachers
which have done many times about
Douglass and my host which was the
Georgia Historical Society said there's
a local gentleman here he's a collector
he'd like to meet you and I said fine
that day I met Walter and Walters
collection is the essential reason I
wrote this new biography I didn't commit
immediately because it was a daunting
task I didn't know if I wanted to take
this on but that collection especially
opened up the last third of Frederick
Douglass's life he's only in his 40s
when the Civil War occurs and the
Emancipation comes but Douglass lives 30
more years to 1895 and lived out in a
remarkable and complicated both public
and family life the core of the Evans
collection are about 10 very large
family scrapbooks that were kept by his
sons plus a lot of family letters and
other kinds of family legal documents
and photographs so that collection gave
me a window like we had never had into
the older Douglass the aging Douglass
the Douglass who becomes the patriarch
of a huge extended family but also the
Douglass who becomes a kind of political
insider in Washington DC and within the
19th century Republican Party so it was
it was access to a third of Douglass's
life we had never seen before and that
collection really is the
I wrote the new biography and I was able
to employ I hope a lot of new insights
about Douglas particularly that latter
part of his life and it's why I
dedicated the book to Walter and Linda
Evans so any anything that surprised you
when you were going through the
materials and what
oh gosh many many things but for example
in these scrapbooks suddenly I happened
upon two handwritten narratives there
are fairly short dozen pages maybe by
two of Douglass's three surviving sons
entitled growing up in the Douglass
household that kind of revealing access
to the memories of his children are
extraordinary but also the scrapbooks
are full of literally thousands of
newspaper clippings from all kinds of
small-town newspapers where Douglass
traveled to lecture the family hired by
the 1880s a clipping service which I
didn't even know existed in the 19th
century was called the American Bureau
and these clippings would come back
labeled American bureau from all kinds
of small town newspapers and that's
because Douglass did ubiquitous speaking
tours every year all through the end of
his life in part to raise money to
finance this very large extended family
he had four surviving adult children 21
grandchildren at least three fictive
siblings who adopted him or he adopted
them and there were always another
variety of hangers-on around Douglass
but I also learned a great deal about
Douglass's political public life in
Washington within the government apart
from the government the scrapbooks and
the Evans collection also gave me access
to insights into the whole variety of
rivalries the Douglas had
with other black leaders from the next
generation who were doing what the next
generation almost always does which was
to try to knock off the great leader so
it was just this endless array of
anecdotes and parts of his aging life
that allowed me to narrate that part of
his life in ways no one had before and
in some ways the older Douglas took over
the story for me I mean I still do the
entire life including the younger heroic
Douglas but there's so many anecdotes I
learned for example well gosh when
Douglas when Douglas his wife died of
his wife of 44 years on Amory Douglas
died in 1882 he came apart and I learned
this from some letters in that
collection and from some newspaper
clippings even he went up to Poland
Springs in Maine for example for about a
month and a half all by himself
just as a retreat but happily he wrote
some letters to his daughter and his
sons which are very revealing about just
what it meant that their mother had died
but then he quickly remarried he well in
a year and a half he remarried
a woman named Helen Pitts who was a
white woman 20 years younger very
well-educated and Anna his first wife
had not been educated in fact had
remained largely illiterate all of her
life Helen Pitts however was the Mount
Holyoke graduate came from an
anti-slavery family had good
abolitionist credentials she had worked
in refugee slave slave refugee camps
during the Civil War
she was very well-read but she was about
the age of Douglass's daughter Rosetta
his oldest child and she was working in
the recorder of Deeds office where
Douglass was the recorder of deeds she
was one of the eighth clerks he had
hired there
four of them were his four children and
one was Helen Pitts and from the press
accounts and other kinds of documents I
learned that he and Helen had decided to
get married but they kept it a total
secret even from his children or
especially from his children and they
got married in secret one afternoon and
the parlor of a black minister now what
year was this 1884 so it's about a year
and a half after his wife Anna had died
they get married one afternoon and a
newspaper reporter walked into the
recorder of Deeds office in late
afternoon and said to Rosetta the
daughter who was working there
did you realize your father just bought
a marriage license up the hall here
because it's in City Hall and that's how
she found out now that exploded in the
press because the most famous
african-american man in the country if
not the world I just married a white
woman in the 1880s tremendous fallout
from that tremendous fall and that and
the Evans collection has a giant
collection of press coverage of this you
can find that in the regular press but I
had it all there in fact an entire
scrapbook is consumed the sons kept all
these clippings now I'm not going into
it all it was a huge scandal this is the
1880s not the 1980's the most famous
black man in the country married a white
woman 20 years younger he got pilloried
from the black press the white press
although he got defended as well he was
a defendant by many of his friends his
children however did not take easily to
it it was a very complicated difficult
part of his story
they never warmed up to Helen to put it
nicely although they said all the right
things to the press so this collection
opened up that story to me which could
have been an entire chapter of the book
I make it a part of the chapter it's
those sorts of elements of Douglass's
life I could go on about this there's
the case where his son-in-law rose
as husband who was not a good husband
I'll leave it there but at one point he
sued Douglas his own son-in-law sued him
that's exploded in the press and Douglas
had to settle out of court with his own
son-in-law this sort of stuff led me to
actually use the label in the book that
Douglass's family his extended family
became in effect the blackfurs family in
Washington DC everything they did good
bad ugly got into the press if there was
a bankruptcy for one of the sons it's in
the press he gets sued it's in the press
he gets sure he gets accused of nepotism
for hiring his four children as his
clerks which it was and at one point he
basically he said sure okay it's a
nepotism but my kids need jobs you know
anyway
it allowed me for a biographer what the
Evans collection allowed me was texture
it gives you anecdotal stories that you
can begin to piece together to show the
nature of a life and as we all know
every day of our lives we live a partly
public life and a partly private life
and if you're doing biography you do
both you have to do both and virtually
nothing is off limits in biography
because you're trying to get a sense of
the person the oven's collection got me
into family life private life and not
just you know there's anything salacious
I'm talking about how life was actually
lived for this aging federal bureaucrat
who also is the most famous abolitionist
in the country who is this heroic
symbolic figure always associated with
slavery and emancipation and the victory
of the Civil War who was always
associated with being you know the head
of his race people would even write to
him black people would write to him and
say dear chieftain of the race Wow
it wouldn't even say dear mr. Douglass
he lived with this kind of well we would
call it celebrity today
didn't use that term they called it Fame
he had a serious problem with how to
manage fame and his reputation and then
have the reputation of his whole
extended family because his kids didn't
all succeed they didn't all do so well
and he's constantly sending the money
constantly helping them out in ways that
really weighed on him as an individual
but then there's so many other public
events that he gets associated with and
gets involved in controversies of all
kinds about issues over the Republican
Party issues over the Kansas migration
Exodus issues over every election year
and then eventually he got appointed
u.s. minister to Haiti which meant
ambassador to Haiti in 1889 when he's in
his 70s and that became very
controversial because of the kinds of
policies expansions policies that he was
asked to enforce there and everything
Douglass did in Haiti was all over the
press so I won't say I fell in love with
the older Douglass that's not the way to
put it at all but I became deeply
fascinated with this latter part of his
life where for so many for so long
people have written about Douglass have
always been less interested in that that
this was the aging man who became this
representative man he had a nice big
house in Washington he held these
federal appointments he was always off
lecturing yeah okay and that was never
as interesting as the young heroic
escaped slave who becomes a great orator
the great abolitionist the the fierce
critic of Lincoln until he supported
Lincoln the fierce proponent of the
Union war effort in the Civil War and of
emancipation and then we just started
left Douglass behind and forgot about
the whole last third of his life no heed
Douglass is just as interesting as this
complicated aging man who never stopped
going on the road
taking a speech on the road trying to
influence and persuade people whether
the question was racism terrorism
violence the right to vote women's
rights you name it he is still and
eventually his last great subject the
last great speech of his life which he
first gives in 1893 and took it on the
road all through 1894 right up until
about two months before he died was a
speech about lynching called lessons of
the hour he wrote as as good a careful
analysis of why lynching was happening
in the 1890s as anyone else did so he's
always out there as the voice the master
of words and language that he had always
been and the Evans collection allowed me
the texture to develop that part of his
life instead of just the early part so
which do you think was easier for you as
a biographer the first part of his life
or this part of his life especially
since as you know not many people knew
about that part of his life mean just
simply because there weren't enough
materials I think available well truth
is I didn't find any of it easier okay
because biography always feels like it's
infinite and by that I mean there's
always something else you can find and I
think if somebody's doing the history of
your life or my life or anyone's life
there's a lot I don't know right and you
question if you're getting it right
exactly getting it right or even getting
it do I know enough about this can I say
anything about this because I don't have
the evidence so on writing the chapters
of the young Douglass the slave Douglass
he's a slave the first 20 years of his
life and he wrote brilliantly about that
in three autobiographies especially the
first two so he is kind of his own guide
for a lot of that although you got to
penetrate that too with some skepticism
writing those chapters was a bit quicker
in part because the source material is
so much
contained the older he gets the more
letters they are the more speeches there
are the more complications that are on
his life the children are growing up
their adults is lots of friendships and
relationships some of which are pretty
conflicted so the older my subject got
the chapters all got longer that was a
problem
and my editor kept trying to pull me
back pulling me back and as you probably
noticed it's a very long book I know and
you know people have asked me what is
your theory of biography I don't know
that yet I have one because you're if I
have a theory of biography it is simply
you tell the story as it was lived you
try to get inside of the life and then
narrate it as it is lived stopping on
and you're making choices all the time
but stopping on the episodes that are
most important and those indeed that you
have the most evidence for and you are
narrating you're telling a story but
you're also trying to recreate a
character a personality a human being
you're trying to help your reader
understand how this person lived and
thought and behaved and you got to say
it when you think this person didn't
behave well or was utterly insensitive
to something or worse but you just kind
of tell it and what I mean by that is I
started out with elaborate outlines was
this 22 chapter outline I just outlined
the whole book and it kept changing it
then changing and I realized finally I
don't know somewhere halfway through I
just throw out the outline and let the
chapters evolve as they do now clearly I
would make a plan that this chapter I'm
going to cover these two years of the
war or this chapter I'm going to cover
these three major episodes during
reconstruction but it kept it always
chronological of course but also it's
still dug it's what's in front of
Douglas what's what's what Douglas is
living and then anybody else who has a
role in that but you know there are no
real theories of biography you tell the
life as it's happening now they're
different kinds of biographies some
biographies are almost entirely public
some biographies are an attempt to tell
all to tell all private life which you
tend to get about novelist and you know
poets the lives of the poets in this
case though my models for this biography
tended to be some of the great literary
biography is because Douglass was such a
writer he wrote millions of words 1,200
pages of autobiography hundreds and
hundreds of the short form political
editorials in his newspaper and then
thousands of speeches almost all of
which we have a text for Wow he wrote
them down so there are millions of words
he's a he's a word master he's a
creature of language so I looked to a
lot of the at least for me my favorite
literary biographies because I'm writing
about a writer at the same time I rang
about a public figure and some writers
are very much public figures so anyway I
guess I'm a biographer now I wanted to
be or not but it's sometimes it kind of
defines itself as you go
I am wondering you know in your first
book Douglas sets out as this radical
outsider okay
you know freed from slavery radical
outsider and then over the course of his
life becomes really a political insider
and as you noted you know was made the
ambassador to Haiti so he explained how
that process happened Wow
it is one of the most important
trajectories of his life and fascinating
trajectories you know what happens to
the old radical outsider always outside
of powered knocking on the doors always
demanding the country live up to its
Creed's and a ferocious radical critic
it's what abolitionists were right
variances the civil war where he was
also a radical critic and then he reaps
victory in the middle of life he's only
in his 40s and it's cause one how many
radicals actually win in their lifetime
and then he has to find new roles new
new functions and he worried he worried
greatly there at the end of the war what
do I do now you know in fact when he
wrote about the end of the war in 65
1865 66 in his last autobiography he
called that chapter vast changes and he
opined in the first paragraph of it with
the famous line from Shakespeare's
Othello
he said well fellas occupation is gone I
am without my community without my
church and in Othello its Othello
expressing the great anxiety that he's
lost his armies lost his status he's
lost everything a fella didn't yet know
he's about to lose his wife and even
kill his wife but that
orrible tragedy but Douglass employs
that moment in a fellow and everything
just loss of all meaning and status well
it turns out he hadn't lost his status
at all he was suddenly under constant
demand as a speaker and he became a real
participant in reconstruction although
he was always frustrated that he
couldn't affect policy as much but where
Douglass found his role is where it had
always been his voice his oratorical
voice and his written voice he found
after the war during reconstruction for
example that he now had access to major
newspapers and major magazines he's no
longer editing his own newspaper which
was always as I would let his own voice
now he could write for the New York
Tribune and the North American review
and the independent these major sort of
progressive journals and magazines and
kind of legitimized him oh yeah legit
amazed him but he was so legitimized as
well as an orator
he's the invited order at the
of the Freedmen's memorial the famous
statue of Lincoln standing and with the
kneeling slave in 1876 where he gave
what I think is the second greatest
speech second only to his fourth of July
speech of 1852 and then with time
Douglass is constantly constantly
pressed and invited to express what does
he think about this what does he think
about that then the Republican Party
finally embraces him and sends him out
on the stump every presidential election
doug has campaigned for every Republican
president from grant to the end in the
1890s not always with a great deal of
Glee he wasn't always happy with what
was happening to the Republican Party as
it moved away from black civil and
political rights and more toward big
business and was paying less attention
by the xviii far less attention by the
1880s to the crisis in the south but he
found his role with his voice it was
always essentially the only weapon
Douglass ever had was his pen and his
voice and he understood that he also
created a new newspaper for awhile for
three years he and his sons edited a new
paper 1870 1873 in Washington called the
new national era is it Douglass and his
sons were the printers and he was the
editor that fell on hard times and he
lost about ten thousand dollars on it
and then he got appointed the president
of the Freedman's Bank in 1874 which
also failed on his watch he admitted he
wasn't a banker it didn't fail because
of him it was already failing when he
took it over so there other he always
called these ventures you know the life
needs ventures and he was always taking
in the next venture excuse me
but the most important venture of his
life was always there in words and by
1881 he writes the third version of his
autobiography called life and times of
Frederick Douglass and one of the things
you have to do if you're his biographer
when you write a biography of someone
who wrote 1,200 pages of autobiography
three times his own version of his life
is always there in front of you the
subject is in the way because he's
already imposing the story on you and
those autobiographies have almost
nothing about his family life his two
marriages his friendships relationships
etc etc it's the public miss the public
hero so you have to find other ways
around that on the other hand those
autobiographies are also not just your
source they're your subject you have to
keep explaining why did this man believe
he had to keep telling his story is it
because he knew he had to be the
representative African American the
former slave who reinvented himself and
then reinvented himself again and again
in this country that always always
desperately wants to believe that we're
reinventing ourselves he's kind of the
prototype for that so he finds all kinds
of new roles but almost always it's
connected to language and words even
after he got a salary for the first time
in his life as marshal of the District
of Columbia and recorder of deeds in the
District of Columbia federal
appointments those brought him a salary
but he still spent half of his life out
on the road giving speeches and writing
new speeches and writing columns and
editorials for all sorts of places when
he was asked down to the end of his life
at age 77 he is still at least at least
probably was 76 he is still out there
and this is something I learned about
Douglass you know when you write
biography you spent a lot of time with
this person there are times when you
don't think you know them at all you
just this is so elusive and then there
are times when you think this I know one
of the things I know
whole thing Deb has had no formal
education spent 20 years as a slave
never a day in his life in a schoolroom
he was a sponge if he met you he would
figure out what he can learn from you he
had no other teachers the world was his
teacher
the people he met were his teachers he'd
learn like he could learn from you and
then he might just discard you go on to
the next person he can learn from that's
the way he was and that didn't always
lend itself the long lasting friendships
the second thing I think I do know about
Douglas is he's one of those people like
maybe a lot of us who didn't know what
he thought about something until he
could write it down he was a writer but
crisis comes up whether that is the
Fugitive Slave Act Lincoln's election
emancipation or some crisis and
reconstruction whatever comes up he goes
to his desk and he writes a new speech
he did it so many times and then that
speech he takes out on the road or he
may give it dozens and dozens of times
to huge audiences and that might be a
fact we're stating - although it's not
necessarily a fact I speculated in the
book that quite likely more Americans
heard Frederick Douglas speak than any
other American of the 19th century wow I
don't think there's any one to truly
compare to him with the possibility a
possible exception at least of Mark
Twain Douglass gave thousands of
speeches he did lecture trips there were
always three and four months long or he
would speak every day or every other day
endlessly throughout his life and it
became a kind of a phenomenon for people
you know I saw Douglass speak or going
to see Douglass speak Millions I can't I
can never come up with such a number but
it is just phenomenal how widespread his
voice became primarily because of his
own
indomitable will to be heard it is kind
of the will to power as the will to
speak and the will to write and he
became I say this in the book especially
at the end he dealt with every subject
there was in the 19th century but of
course his his his Krait subjects were
slavery racism emancipation the civil
war reconstruction what all this meant
these are the these are the pivots of
American history in the 19th century and
he became in many ways a kind of a prose
poet of of American democracy of those
issues he dabbled in real poetry but it
really wasn't his best mode his his
poetry was in his prose and that's where
one finds the the prophetic voice and
hence my use of the word prophet in the
title he had methods and ways with
language that few other Americans have
ever had so what would you like your
readers to take away from your book that
Douglass was for that 19th century and
still is in some ways the prose poet of
what it means to be an American what it
means what our Creed's actually mean how
our Creed's had to be literally
destroyed Andrea and reinvented how the
country the Republic was crushed in the
Civil War and then reinvented out of
that war but I'd also like them to
understand his sheer endurance and by
that I mean that his physical endurance
travel and putting up with the hardships
and all that but it was endurance of the
problem of racism and white supremacy
how you could continue to face that
argue with it argue against it day in
day out when almost most almost all of
your people are still enslaved and
there's very little hope they'll ever be
freed in your own lifetime if it's the
1850s or the 1840s when he's starting
out
and how you endure his story of
endurance of the racism he himself
personally encountered early in his
career when he would encounter you know
discrimination he'd be thrown off a
railroad car he'd be not denied a dinner
in a hotel etc etc he would often react
with outrage I mean just she anger and
rage as he got older and encounter this
and he kept drinking he got Jim crowd
more times than anyone could ever count
but he got older he would begin to even
process it with a certain absurd sense
of humor because what else can you do
right I mean for example later in life
he sometimes would still get asked at a
hotel or a you know guest house to not
eat in the dining room with the rest of
the white people and at least two
instances I have in the book he would
get up in the middle of the dining room
and his loud baritone voice and he'd say
well then word of the dogs eek tell me
tell me where your dogs are take me
where the dogs are only with the dogs
and pretty soon he's got the whole
dining room on his side they're saying
oh don't make that poor man eat with the
dogs and the owner has to sitting
seating now you know that's a kind of
endurance as well but it shows us you
know we may see Frederick Douglass as
this great order this great writer this
great man of the 19th century but he's
still had to endure sometimes on a daily
basis this kind of hideous individual
daily racism and the ways he found to
endure that
at the same time analyzing it
criticizing it trying to destroy it is
kind of a central threat of his life and
I want readers to get that that you
don't defeat something like this by just
throwing your body at it you don't
defeat it by sheer outrage alone you
have to feed it you have to defeat it
with with wit and cunning and probably
even a sense of humor
has been such a pleasure David thank you
and just in the interest has time I
there's so many more questions and so
much more we could have talked about in
your book but there was plenty left for
readers to hurried so hopefully they
will do that so thank you
Thank You Marilyn pleasure to be here
for more information about Professor
blight and his work please visit our
website at macmillan report yale.edu be
sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale
you bet thank you
you